did you ever meet hendricks yeah oh you
did yeah did you ever get to play with
him
uh not live
not live backstage you went backstage
where was this uh youngstown ohio back
in the early 70s yeah okay and you're
what doing a concert yeah james gang
concert at that james gang hendrix and
uh and uh sliding the family stones all
on the same bill
member in those days wow yeah you had
three headliners on the show and who
opened that show uh we did the james
game yeah unbelievable what a show so
hendrix is backstage and what happened
he's backstage we're in in a like uh uh
dressing room
which is like where a hockey team
changes or something you know not
glamorous yeah so yeah
we finished in and we're in the same
dressing room so
uh
he's sitting playing his guitar and i
come in with mine right and uh and you
have a jam session so a little bit yeah
i showed you in my guitar and he showed
me his do you get intimidated by a guy
like that no he was a wonderful guy of
course i'm intimidated by his talent i
mean
by him he he had an aura i mean he had
feathers on i mean it was terrifying
well you know you talked about that i
read that clapton and a bunch of other
guys at the time who were considered top
guitarists all went to see jimi hendrix
when he first came on the scene they
went to a club and they all looked at
each other and they went
[ __ ] we don't even like really the hell
are we doing what are we doing that's
the famous story generally thought by
the community yeah what the hell are we
doing did you feel that way yeah you did
when you played with when you played
with him did he say oh wow joe maybe we
should get together in a studio and do
something together or never got that no
i never got that far but uh he showed me
his guitar and i i
saw i paid attention to what how the
heavy strings light strings right
how high are the strings what's the
action because he was a tough one you
know because he was left-handed right
everything was backwards that's why he
sounded like that
none of us right-handed guitar players
could do what he was doing was he
playing a lefty guitar no he was playing
a right-handed guitar
upside down oh
wow that's why he sounded like that and
that's why we couldn't crack the code oh
my god that's fascinating yeah that's
why we were all hitting ourselves in the
head but that's why you're a great
guitar player because you're a student
sitting with jimi hendrix it's a master
class yeah wow even if it's
three or four minutes
and i had a les paul
and he looked at that and uh he was
really really nice and and just a a good
guy
you